[Music]
what is up there reject nation we are
here eagle fang rejects so excited we're
gonna watch the second episode of season
four of the ck show hit that like button
if you end up enjoying our reaction
punch it or something some some karate
reference judo chuck that subscribe
button and to get notified when our next
reaction is is up eagle crane our
patreon notified
check joining and coming to super reject
today covers so much crap over there my
goodness it just doesn't stop thanks to
the boys at prepper for editing down
these highlights you guys have great
form and technique ah [ __ ] andrew's here
hey follow him on the movie source
channel
he knows more about karate kid than the
actual creators of cobra kai the netflix
series check out our review for the last
episode he points out a whole bunch of
unnecessary facts and that's what makes
it for a great video that's just me
putting you down to make myself feel
better about my own insecurity thanks
greg i did understand that reference
with the judo chop though so yeah austin
powers
it's a mike myers movie where he plays
an indian guru
[Laughter]
what's up that was jaden smith
that would be crazy though huh it's the
next season
yes dad is the producer one of them
everyone's going multiverse now
there's so much sponsorships in this
[ __ ]
i saw spider-man 3k many times no [ __ ]
man
likes bully mcguire
i lost this pop-tart look at this idiot
dancing
well no no no no i think it's called the
uh i'm trying not to shoot my pants
dance
oh he's finally gonna be a character say
good one larusso
smooth is a smurf's ass right that deck
was the perfect teachable moment you
just tanked my entire week kids know
they're here to learn karate you don't
need to trick them with chores
[Laughter]
some days i'll toss them in a cement
mixer other days i'll find a hornet's
nest for them to kick let's not do this
is there really a difference you're
still teaching aggression some kids need
a little aggression let's give it a try
i teach you miyagi dough you teach me
eagle factor oh interesting
deal
no don't need to shake on it
he lured cobra caught from terrorism i'm
tori
are we waiting on anybody or is it just
you
oh you could have your little tournament
but if you touch
one hair on her head before then you'll
be scrubbing toilets in prison for the
rest of your life that's right electric
chair is everything okay here man i
don't know is it
miss i don't want my soup to get cold
can we just hell up
put away your uniform i've had enough of
your attitude you're fired oh yeah
best place gotta be on the health
inspection they hide the sign and say
you can't see it
and i saw one of the cook's dippest
balls in the miso
oh that must hurt his bubbles he's got
it
sounds tasty
anthony's got a love interest new kid
get in there
we'll get you some gym clothes next week
larusso thompson you're in too
oh my god
can't put baby larissa as a bully i'll
cover the ballerina
why are you a dick
oh he's got that eye contact
that i had the tiger cross over
lay up good
love it love to see it i told you okay
they can't those moves cause like
permanent brain damage ah
whatever
ace it was an accident [ __ ]
hey uh come on give the new kid a break
aunt we've gone against finish
they're gonna both compete for that girl
you wanna learn how to fight defensively
you got to change your instincts go
fight the fight defense is boring
offense will always be more badass
fruit in your beer figures
whoa just like miyake did there's your
easter egg
at the beach
miyagi dough may seem boring
but don't forget it saved your ass a few
weeks ago from crease and that wasn't
the first time
[Applause]
nobody was more badass than mr miyagi
honk honk mr miyagi did whip everyone's
ass the only time he got hit was once
and cried at part two
show me paint the fence
nice
nice
just part of the lesson
enough
nickel's in my office you're fired
did something happen with your mother
no
it's nothing
lost my job okay she's gonna go threaten
her boss
[Music]
oh [ __ ] yeah that's what i'm talking
about man she saw his shirt and she knew
what game it all makes sense
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
knowledge
it's like a boat or a dry land this is
pretty deep
i like this walk on the right side of
the road
safe
walk down the middle
it's just like craig at part two center
yourself johnny
look inward
find your balance
imagine if johnny had been trained by
miyagi
what if he ends up just still
[Music]
this thing isn't even level
well get ready
because tomorrow you learn real man
karate
oh i can't wait to hear all about the
illustrious history and wise teachings
of the eagle fang
check this out
[Music]
oh bagel bites my man pizza get bacon
look at photos of you
[Laughter]
every now and then some dungeon lore
cosplay come on i dance in front of the
school bus
don't tell anyone i told you that
oh no it's a prank it's a prank isn't it
don't worry your secret is safe with oh
damn that sucks yeah uh
ask him who's his favorite character
dr scribble box
dr scribble bottom oh my god that that
is like the lamest character he's like
this sad stupid chipmunk with with with
big ears and a lab coat who like uh he
mixes like health potions and yeah
they're gonna become best friends i i
got into character for this prank guys
leah and a bunch of other dungeon lord
losers are meeting up at balboa park
tomorrow night tell him to cosplay as mr
scrap alas or whatever uh why why what's
the plan we're gonna kill him
i don't like this i'll do that to so
many kids should just do a shooter
mcgavin gilmore take a grade
get the water
[Music]
crease
no i know
about the deal that you struck with my
husband and johnny
and i just want you to know that
whatever happens at that tournament
i will make sure
you lose
oh damn she's gonna rig it that girl has
to pay the bills
put food on the table
all by herself so you might want to
leave the girl alone
or deal with the consequences
there we go
not all kids are as lucky as yours
yeah tori stole a [ __ ] she's your
favorite character
i like watching tori i don't want to be
able to get it wrong i do
an eagle embraces the pain all your life
the world's been trying to make you less
of a man
light beer
veggie burgers automatic transmissions
automatic transfers
human response to dangerous fight or
flight the eagles response is fight and
flight
this does look more fun
that's it
yeah
come on oh he's getting into it
oh damn he's so into this
that's what i'm talking about
[Applause]
there's a little bit of cobra kai in you
man
i really did shoot this at balboa
it you park post that no don't
oh [ __ ]
he just broke her phone
just by dropping it on the grass you
guys were being [ __ ]
what did you just call us
yeah peer pressure
[Music]
oh damn
damn you're good
it's in the bush gentlemen what do you
think they play by the rules
the only rule in this league is
intimidation
that's why striking first is so
important
[Applause]
oh
that's spearing at least a double minor
a raft spearing
double minor
come on
oh he looks pissed
oh no
oh no
he's setting up a fight
he says you're a [ __ ] he could kick
your ass any day of the week hey enough
all right cut it out oh come on down
i need to sally
for my friend here he's a little
unstable we're working through it sorry
[Music]
you see what i just did there
that's called de-escalation
you should try it sometime
during the tournament because you i
spent half the game in the box yeah but
you still eat that'll win it was great
so you can kick my ass any day of the
week is that right no i didn't say that
he
the chopping prices guy from tv
let's get that smoking hypernet running
the place
oh now you've done it maybe i'll take
her for a test drive
all right shotgun
strike first haha foursome let's do it
guys
[Music]
yeah yeah
just like meow you taught him
damn
damn
spearing
nice
[Music]
nice work never insult a man's wife nice
work larusso way to assert your
dominance without you
no be there
that's great
no feet there
this is great
[ __ ] oh straight take one more step
towards me and i'll snap you in half
like a pencil
why don't i step into this karate
situation
thanks for letting a fire under me
hey uh should i start wearing protective
gear to work
i don't feel safe
one of them even knows karate
oh
no [ __ ] i was wondering what was going
on don't worry about a little
bro i know a guy who can help
he kicked my ass oh man
what a twist oh no
we thought the brother was dead
but no he was just robbie's cell mate
which is as good as being dead yeah
in this world that's right
[ __ ] they're so mean to that kid they
are awful too yeah definitely has his
brother's aggression
it reminds me of how john treated kids
in school mm-hmm i'm just kicking asses
left and right
i could see john being that kind of kid
john was so mean everyone
what's up [ __ ] for brains lick my boot
snort your chocolate milk yeah
[Laughter]
oh this thing looks good i'm gonna take
it from me i'm gonna shove your face in
it
and other authentic holy movies
there's so many fascinating dramatic
things happening right now
i really love
the juxtaposition of what's happening
with miyagi doe
and eagle thing because
it's
like i don't know i just i expected him
to kind of be into it
but i think it's really smart that
instead of focusing on teaching their
students how to blend it both the only
way they can show their students how to
adopt both styles is they themselves as
leaders have to adopt each other's
styles as well and understand the
benefits of it because so as like
as as oppressive towards miyagi dough as
johnny was you can see there are still
definitely shades of him that really did
enjoy and understand it and i'm sure
some of that will come back into the
fold and it was very much more overt
with danny enjoying
the lessons of eagle fang which i
thought was a blast and like watching
their dynamic and understanding uh is
something very unique to offer to this
the karate kid saga the world because
you don't really get you got some of
that in like karate kid 3 but it was all
just you know like manipulation in a way
to destroy daniel really or here uh
there's truly you're seeing like the
benefits of both and i like that you're
getting those opposing
perspectives especially with them
because now they can start instilling it
upon their children hopefully hopefully
hopefully
hopefully all right you took it away
john take it away no be there no be
there
no absolutely that was
definitely the fun of this episode and
for the second episode i feel like that
makes a lot of sense and i like that it
did that thing where you know it's like
we don't do too much with terry silver
we don't really see the kids we're
focused in
on yeah danny and johnny learning this
lesson and then a couple other you know
main side plots but that was yeah a lot
of fun getting to see johnny tap into
yeah the the zen elements that could
serve to help him and then danny uh
being able to let out some of those
things that you know he crams down in
order to be level headed and whatnot and
so yeah uh in sticking true to the
characters i thought they did a really
nice job of yeah making them fish out of
water in each other's styles but
ultimately then bringing it back to that
uneasy respect
and yeah like it almost felt like this
was the real start of the season and the
previous episode makes more sense to be
the actual kickoff because it's much
more momentous but this seems to be like
okay now we're underway we're figuring
out how like you said these two styles
can co-exist and uh and yeah it's nice
to know that off-screen all this time
danny's son has been uh becoming a dick
yeah behind the scenes when you lose
weight you become a dick that's just how
it works in the world uh since they
didn't really talk much about uh johnny
and daniel i'm just gonna talk about
those two um good good this is coming
out
i did enjoy that i mean i i know
somewhere in a different uh multiverse
there is a what-if episode where miyagi
trained johnny lawrence so i guess we
got a little glimpse of that but i
actually like how they focused a lot too
on uh torrey greg's favorite character i
like tori no i know i know i just i'm
just uh like tori's story yeah but i i
did like how again we get that layer of
you know amanda obvious for obvious
reasons uh very understandable she hates
this this girl's got she's feels this uh
this
[ __ ] greg has been terrorizing her
daughter giving her scars mentally and
physically so you know when we got when
we uh you know peeled into that layer
where uh that that conversation with
chris and amanda i really like that you
know amanda salka there is a different
side now i'm feeling some empathy toward
this uh girl that i freaking hate uh
that's being horrific to my daughter but
again i i like seeing uh that i think
that's where the show is like
is really different for me than uh
anything uh crying it does because i
mean i love karate kid but this show
really gets deep into layers of
characters like uh i mean obviously not
comparing you know you know i get two
two hour films here and obviously this
gets ten episodes each season but i do
like how we get really deep in the
layers of these characters and seeing
that not everything is so black and
white
yeah
yeah that's probably one of my favorite
things about this show in particular
even like little moments like when chris
brings in tori into the office like you
can tell he really cares about her
that's a nice thing and especially
having them face off with each other
like as much as crease merits this sort
of constant suspicion at the same time
that was like it did almost feel like a
parent-to-parent conversation even
though you know chris is also getting in
amanda's head and all that like that was
a good exchange but what a [ __ ] move on
amanda's end
that one bag of groceries is not gonna
fix anything whatever you had i got you
fired here's some groceries you have to
know that i hate amanda so much i would
have much preferred to offer her a job
outright i thought she was gonna yeah i
was actually a good guy i was actually
thinking that was a good call but i'm
like i don't know if tori would want to
work i know it's money but i guess if
she can't find a job anywhere else and
that's the only job she can get maybe
that would be very inconsiderate to her
daughter
i mean i get that tori's pride was
really hurt in that moment
like i get it that makes sense that
would be a great moment though sam comes
to the larusso audio room and sees her
working there like what the hell is
going on oh yeah and obviously we got to
talk about that incredible twist with uh
robbie's cellmate's little brother
uh you know being painted out to be just
this kid that's the the daniel of this
of this uh episode where as we remember
daniel and that uh the first karate kid
from 1984 was bullied by johnny although
there's many videos out there saying
that daniel was actually yeah
but uh yeah i like how they they played
that off where um you know he had his
embarrassing moment where he thought the
girl was messaging him you can tell even
though you guys called anthony a bully
to me it's uh it's bully by proxy of
being peer pressured he doesn't really
want to be a bully of course uh but and
i want to know he's an awful human okay
he's terrible amanda's a [ __ ]
i don't
the one glaring question i want to know
from this episode how the hell did that
phone crack from falling on grass i want
to know that answer that is fair you're
in a world
in an area that before we live
so many locations i'm like balboa park
it's like right down the street for a
while every several time watching this i
used to run guys i used to run there all
the time yeah break phones easily there
and uh you know in a world where a phone
breaks like that that easily i can also
say that in this world
of the
los angeles no one is obsessed with
karate this much in school so i will
i will accept a phone breaking so easily
to create dramatic tension he must have
right he chewed chopped that phone maybe
it was fun getting that time with that
kid because i'll be honest
i was like he's got to be connected as
some kid from karate kid yeah and uh
i can't think of any important black
characters from the karate kids it was
my first reaction
minus mr miyagi it's a very white french
who is this jackie chan's son i was like
i can't think of anyone
um
this is so funny they do got to do a
karate kid multiverse when this show
starts like really going to [ __ ] like
when they
they've bled this show out too much and
then the writing just gets poor season
eight they gotta they gotta do cobra kai
mo they gotta do multiverse or like they
get jackie chan and jaden smith over
come on i'll grab it anthony's not gonna
want anyone to remember who he is
you know you're gonna want to watch that
[ __ ] man
who wouldn't want to watch it it sounds
so stupid but you're like i'd watch it
i'd watch jayden smith
and fight daniel
we're gonna see julie from next karate
kid in this too i hope so man let's get
hillary swank on board let's do it what
about that redhead chick from uh karate
kid three
ah
the w what was that that teenage whis uh
she did a witch movie back in 1989 this
is why you're here retirement man
huh
yeah what's happening too many
conversations we're not listening to
each other guys it's about a big part of
improv he's got to listen
and not have too many pauses
and i will continue listening
until a good comment comes to mind
uh yeah i mean what more is there to say
it's great great stuff
great stuff guys great scott i love this
show oh and one last thing has nothing
to do with the episode but ralph macho
is a huge hockey fan i did uh you know i
was actually noticing the uh you could
tell on his face just how happy ralph
macho was to be there he's a huge new
york islanders fan so i thought that was
really cool how we got to see his
character
be involved in a hockey fight yeah
really crossing over into the real life
and blurring the lines which one's which
where does ralph macchio end and daniel
russo begin
at the hockey rink
it's it has been feeling more like ralph
macchio's show though i've noticed yes i
mean i mean it's been feeling like an
ensemble still but i have felt like
before it was johnny's show yeah and now
this one is johnny's felt more of a
supporting character in the last last
two episodes versus
danny but i'm sure that'll change so i'm
sure there'll be some very focused
johnny episodes it does seem like in the
back and forth of them learning each
other's styles there's a more of a who
distance for johnny to go
so yeah it puts danny in control more
frequently
all right guys
cobra kai
never dies let's uh we got a third one
to watch but it's the new year so we're
only watching two right now we'll let
you know how the schedule goes
later on these are going to come out in
a weird order
we're going to try to dish them out
this is for you
hey
bye